so what do you do what haters push
apocalyptic fears about your next
horrible move you troll them which is
what trump did to all those nervous
Nancy's fretting that he may never leave
office
remember Maher last week if he loses he
won't go I've been saying that since
before he got elected if he loses Trump
he won't go I've been saying that since
before he got elected crazy it's pure
projection after all we've been crushing
bill in the ratings but he's still going
nowhere
apparently Martha amendment 22 was a
tiny handgun it's actually a law that
sets turd my limits this fantasy that
the outgoing president won't leave is
akin to the losing hockey team refusing
the handover the Stanley Cup or jussie
Smollett claiming he won't leave Empire
or Seth Meyers pretending he's funny
Trump knows this and can't resist having
some fun tweeting Sunday that his
supporters demand that I stay longer who
knows a third term maybe maybe more not
only does this tease his irrational
critics it gets out there real fear that
they can't beat him that he won't go
after not the first but the second term
meaning there will be more so Trump
critics are already getting the public
to think past the re-election to Trump's
third term it's like when a car salesman
has you talking about long drives up the
coast even before you bought the new
ride and you're still living in Kansas
still before you know it the keys are in
your hand and Trump's back behind the
wheel and the Dems are sitting at the
bus stop checking their watch waiting
for 2024 that's great
Thank You Dana so go to you first for
complimenting it always works out that
way doesn't it no Jesse to that point
Trump knows how to have fun with his
critics doesn't he
Emily forget these - oh no I'm kidding
no no who would like to answer that
first I'm out of the picture and okay I
think for a few reasons one they need a
new conspiracy because collusion died so
they have to prop that up they also need
this to justify the impeachment push you
know he's not going to leave if we beat
them so we have to impeach them also
there's a psychological component
they're basically admitting that the
media has tried all they can to nail
this guy and to take him out and even if
someone does beat him at the ballot box
he still won't leave so they're saying
this is why all the stuff we threw at
him wasn't gonna work anyway
yeah because he's so tough and he's so
nasty and he's so dirty that nothing
would have worked and that's why
everything that we threw at him didn't
work and they're making themselves feel
better but this is based off of all
these polls that are coming out that are
showing you know Trump losing in a
landslide to Budaj edge or something
more Eliason tweeted some great things
for context I'd like wand to pay
particular close attention June 1983
Mondale up ten points on Reagan remember
how that turned out
June 19 one HW Bush beating an unnamed
Democrat by 30 points June 95 Dole
beating Clinton and June 2001 an unnamed
Republican smoking Barack Obama so it's
very early so let's just keep our powder
dry all right one key that was that way
I Debbie over to the various thinking
passed the sale yeah that's what you're
saying with yeah yeah I think that's
what I think they're doing that by
accident they're not meaning to do it
but they're doing it just to be clear
you think Trump is trolling the
Democrats by his tweet that we shouldn't
take it seriously all right so I think
Trump is highly unpredictable hope you
agree to that yes I do I think this is a
man who says that he would violate the
law by taking information from foreign
countries for an election which is a
felony and I thought true seriously
right I wasn't here to defend that okay
but that's what he said no he said he
had to me the FBI it seems to me that
for nothing sort of beyond bounds or out
of bounds when it comes to Trump so he
may be trolling but I will say this much
and this is partly response to Jesse
that he fired pollsters who told him he
might be losing
now fire the ones that he thought leaked
it yeah but there's part of the whole
team shouldn't be fire leaguers he's
upset about this you know I just think
if he hadn't said before the election
that if he lost to Hillary
he might not accept the the election
results I would say here but now it's
like both sides are feeding each other
because he's given people a real reason
to think this guy will play don't
believe that he's gonna stay if you lose
it's impossible for this thing we don't
believe you and Greg every day saying
that the power of Trump supporters is
such they make excuses for whatever so
if he said you know what this election
was great one this is um I will admit on
the show right now if Trump refuses to
leave office and sits in the Oval like
this I will not defend that Emily what I
find interesting about this delusion is
how little investment most normal people
have in this whole situation like if
Trump gets reelected I'm like I'm cool
with it if he's not oh well I had four
years of Trump which was still a
hilarious phenomenon that we'll never
see again but it's not an emotional
event for me right is it an emotional
event for you you have plenty of other
things in your life you have a car and
the job I do yes no it is not an
emotional event I think it's so
ridiculous that the what-if two to four
year to two to six years from now is
actually something that is like covered
and taking up inches on newspaper and
you saw the Washington Examiner said it
is a very real and super serious
prospect that we should all be worried
about and start preparing for is it
Trump refusing to leave the White House
or is it nuclear war because I feel like
that could fit in there I mean it's
ridiculous a lost reservist Luthor yeah
it was an it was an opinion it it was in
our research packet anyway the point is
that it's clearly ridiculous and
hyperbole and it's wasting everyone's
time to even be talking about it but the
weird thing Dana is that these are not
dumb people saying these absurd things
which kind of tells you that it's like
the like satanic rituals and daycare
centers
kind of thinking it's that thing that
overcomes you yes for the reason I
complimented you is
the thinking past the sale piece because
I think that's really interesting
because I think in their heart of hearts
they know how hard it is to beat an
incumbent president that they've they
they say Stu things are unfair like
they'll say the Electoral College is
unfair and that the that there will be
voter suppression to the extent that
somebody like Stacey Abrams still thinks
she should have been President so now
this is actually just a third thing yeah
they could add to it I don't see how he
I think that if he loses it might come
back to me or yeah yeah he's gonna be
like okay I just did this job I'm gonna
go do something else what's it you first
will make some phone calls about a new
hotel and Tulum and then he'll go play
golf but he'll never stop being he'll
get an hour on Fox right yes I didn't
wait wait not five o'clock all right